(audience cheers and applauds)
- So, here's the exciting thing.
First of all, they don't
usually do it that long.
You are amazing.
They love you.
Yeah.
- Well thanks,
it's a beautiful audience.
- I'm just saying,
they like Chance!
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Y'all look good.
It's also a beautiful set, yo.
This is probably one of the nicest sets
I've ever been on.
- Thank you!
(audience cheers and applauds)
But here's the thing,
so we're actually talking
to a couple of cops.
And I know that you do a lot
to help out your community.
- Thanks.
- And I think that
that's an amazing thing.
You want everything to be peaceful,
you want it to be great,
you want everybody to be respected.
And is that a big thing for you?
Especially coming from Chicago?
- Yeah, totally.
So I work with this,
I founded this non-profit in Chicago
called Social Works.
Our main focus is youth,
so youth education and like civics.
Making sure that their schools are funded.
So we actually donated a million dollars
a couple of years ago.
- Wow.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Wow.
- For CBS.
But it's actually,
it's started to kind of funnel
out into a bunch of other things.
So now we deal with homeless population,
homeless and transient population.
And then also mental health
has been a big thing.
So I donated a million dollars
to mental health last year.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- Mental health is a big deal everywhere.
- Yeah.
- We can all be affected by it personally,
but also just in the way
that our families operate,
when we find out how
close it can hit to home.
It just lets you know your proximity to it
is much closer than you think.
So yeah, that's why I got involved,
and it's always been important to me.
- I think that's amazing, man.
(audience claps)
You're doing such a good thing
with your spotlight.
It's cool.
- Thank you.
- And you also,
you just,
not you,
but your girl had another baby, right?
Your second child, right?
- Yes, my wife had--
(audience cheers and applauds)
- That's three females in your house.
- Yeah.
- That's a lot of
estrogen, Chance (laughs)
- A lot of girl energy, for sure.
- There's a lot of female empowerment
going on at your house. (laughs)
- Yeah, they're definitely
empowered right now!
- Do you feel like the odd man out?
- Sometimes.
I think it's good to have that,
'cause as a dude I hang
out with mostly dudes.
And we get very stinky
and loud and stuff all the time.
It's good to come home
and just have a whole bunch of princesses
that are not stinky or loud.
- That is pretty true.
Why is that though, Chance?
'cause I have been on a
bus with boys as well.
And that's why I generally
stay on my own bus now.
- Yeah, good idea.
- But what is it with men on tour?
Is a shower offensive or?
- We just can't help ourselves.
I don't know what it is,
what it is.
- It's a true thing.
- Stank.
- All right.
And I actually love this.
'cause you pushed,
you pushed going back on tour
because of paternity leave.
- Yeah.
- Which I love!
Because men never get that.
I thought that was awesome!
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Thanks, yeah.
- And just so you know,
from a woman that's had children,
your wife loves you for it.
Because being left at
home with all of that
is a lot.
- Yeah, I mean
when I went on tour right
after my oldest was born,
I think like three years ago.
I went our tour two
weeks after she was born.
So that was the time that her mom really,
really needed my help.
And now we got two kids,
which if anybody doesn't know,
is way harder than
having one kid! (laughs)
There's a lot of demand for attention!
But yeah,
so overall it's
an overwhelming experience for both of us
and I can't imagine what it would be like
for her to have to do that by herself.
- Isn't that crazy?
My mom was a single mom,
and I always look at that and I'm like,
"What?"
- I can't imagine.
- I don't even know
what I would have done.
Here's the thing too.
I love your love story.
I just recently heard
about your love story
and how you met your wife,
and how later in life it happened.
Can you do a quite synopsis for us?
'cause it's sweet.
- Yeah, quick story.
People love to hear this story.
(audience laughs)
So my mother used to work
at a real estate agency
from my wife's mother.
And they basically would
throw these office parties
that they would all bring their kids to.
And one time I went to one
and they were doing a Destiny's Child
dance
and I saw her
and I was like, "I like what I see."
- I can get into that.
(audience laughs)
- And so,
but then I didn't see her for about,
let's just say a long time.
About 10 years.
And we met each other at a festival.
♪ Reunited ♪
- And it feel so good.
- So good, Chance.
(audience laughs)
- So good, right?
But yeah, we saw each other.
And hit it off.
And then we stared dating.
- That's crazy.
- And we had Kensli,
and then we got married.
And now we have Marli.
- That's so cool!
(audience applauds)
What a beautiful love story!
I love that!
- That's us!
- I love it! I love it!
- We look good.
- Y'all look real good!
- Thank you.